CHRIS PRATT
What's up everybody?
Chris Pratt here.
They've given me a camera
and a list of rules.  All of which...
...I'm gonna ignore.
To be reunited with this Guardians
family for Volume 3,
it's really fantastic.
ZOE SALDAÑA
We're genuine fans, so there's something
really sweet about geeking out on set.
[Laughing]
JAMES GUNN
You had me at...
POM KLEMENTIEFF
Hello.
[Laughing]
KEVIN FEIGE
The Guardians is about humor.
It's about action. It's about
cosmic adventures.
NEBULA
Drax, sit up.
DRAX
It's what it's here for!
PETER QUILL
Drax, it's called a sofa.
It's not a bed.
DRAX
Well, I find it hard to believe
it doesn't have multiple purposes.
KEVIN FEIGE
But it's really about this found family.
MANTIS
Don't forget where we came from.
KAREN GILLAN
This is a Rocket origin story.
We are learning more and more
about what Rocket has been through.
PETER QUILL
We were always searching for a family,
until we found each other.
DRAX
Yeah!
ROCKET
Let's give the galaxy
something to remember us by.
POM KLEMENTIEFF
It's so beautiful.
Everything is in the details.
CHRIS PRATT
Its imagination, music, beautiful imagery.
It's really a fantastic story from the
brain of a mad genius, James Gunn.
JAMES GUNN
Everything that drives it is that
emotional center of all of these
characters who were all outsiders.
PETER QUILL
We have been running our whole lives.
ROCKET
Pete, I'm done running.
DAVE BAUTISTA
I love everybody,
and I'm so proud of what
we've accomplished.
DRAX
I want you all to know that
I am grateful to fight
beside my friends.
CHRIS PRATT
It's another rock opera.
It's really fantastic and it
wraps it up in a way that
really only James could.
PETER QUILL
Are you ready...
...for one last ride?
ROCKET
We'll all fly away together...
...into the forever...
PETER QUILL
[Screams]
ROCKET
...and beautiful sky.
♫ Since you been gone ♫
CHRIS PRATT
Thank God I don't operate the camera
for this movie, because if
I did, it would look terrible.